>>(Cliff): Good morning everyone. Figured
we'd do a morning talk today before our inboxes
get out of control so glad that you're able
to join us this early. The Authors at Google
program is proud to host Jonathan Spira today.
He's going to discuss an issue very near and
dear to us, that of information overload.
Google's mission is of course is to organize
the world's information, but what many of
the public doesn't understand is that we're
also there to make it universally accessible
and useful. So we're in a constant battle
against information overload; whether it's
the relevance of our search results, the use
of priority inbox in Gmail, or recent innovations
like the Google+ Circles as a way of sharing
information among friends.
So Jonathan Spira today speaks to us about
that in his new book about information overload.
He is the CEO and Chief Analyst of Basics
which is a thought leader in the world of
information overload and his interests also
extend to photography as well. He co-wrote
a very influential book about the history
of photography.
Since this book is about information overload
I'll stop my introduction here.
Please join me in welcoming Jonathan to Google.
[applause]
>>Jonathan Spira: Thank you, thank you very
much Cliff. Good morning everyone both here
and in virtual. I'd like to first thank Cliff
very much for inviting me to this.
This is a topic near and dear to my heart
as I know too many people at Google and many
people who use Google tools. We think of information
it's kind of too much of a good thing.
But first, before we start, and both for everyone
here in the room and everyone watching virtually,
how many of you here have Smartphones with
you?
[pause]
Everyone almost, no, really? Do you ever use
a Smartphone? Okay cool, that's great. A lot
of people are tethered to them. Can you just
take them out and show me, I'll hold mine
up too, if you don't mind and if you're in
virtual land just do the same with us please.
Sort of like the old TV shows where you used
to connect the dots on the TV screen or something.
Could you turn them off by the way?
[laughter]
Ah, [chuckles] while you have them out just
press that off button. Ah, I do that not because
I don't want you to get any email or pay attention
to that at all, more it's a question just
to sort of point out the separation anxiety.
When I do that in large physical crowds of
people, when a lot of people are not attending
virtually, if you saw the look of horror on
some people's faces, especially in like really
uptight business circles, they're like, "What?
You want me to turn this off? To disconnect?"
The fact that we can disconnect, the fact
that some people don't even have Smartphones
is very refreshing to me. I actually don't
get too much information over my Smartphone,
in the interest of disclosure I try and keep
that to a minimum.
But it's interesting when we think of information
one of the earliest ways we kept information
was on the tablet and it's just kind of ironic
that things haven't really changed very much
in terms of our use of tablets. I can't figure
it out but we just keep using tablets for
information.
Before I really get in to this though, I did
bring a few friends of mine along to talk
about the problem of information overload.
So if you can listen to them for just a moment
I'd appreciate it.
>>Larry Bowen: Information overload basically
slows me down because I'm interacting with
information that's irrelevant, out of context.
>>Peter Miles: [inaudible] the reality today
is that it comes at you at such a high volume
you have to learn very quickly how to prioritize
that information and filter out what's useful
and what's not useful.
>>Max Christoff: I feel my pulse quickening
I'm so engrossed in trying to deal with the
emails that are coming in, the instant messages
that are popping up on the screen, the phone
calls coming in simultaneously. It's not a
good feeling.
>>Matt Brezina: Sometimes it gets a little
frustrating. If I don't check it I almost
feel like something's missing in my life.
If I'm sitting with no TV on, no iPhone in
my hand, and no computer in front of me I
kind of feel lonely.
>>Andy Chew: There's no question that the
amount of information I receive makes it harder
for me to prioritize.
>>Jonathan Spira: Well, as you can see a lot
of these people are completely broken up about
the problem. So I never saw that happen before
but.
I wanna cover a couple of things and I also
want to invite you to ask any questions as
we go along. I am imminently interruptible,
I don't mind interruptions, in fact I'd love
to hear questions so we are sort of contextual
in where ever I am. Just stop me please, if
I don't see you just jump up a little warn
and stop me.
I'm gonna cover some changes in how we work,
how we look at information overload, what
it is, and what we can do.
One of the problems that I noticed, and just
by background, I've been researching the problem
of information overload indirectly for over
20 years; I've been studying how people work,
how people collaborate, share information,
what people do with information, and you won't
be surprised to know that there's problems,
there's things that get in the way.
And ultimately after studying and interviewing
people and watching how people work we found
that information overload, and this goes back
15 years, was a significant problem. At the
time, however, everyone was so giddy about
the fact that we had email. It was just so
easy to cc a couple of thousand extra colleagues.
It was just so easy to share content and push
it out to so many people that it really didn't
matter. Nobody thought it was a significant
problem. People actually thought I was kind
of nuts for bringing it up because, "Oh no,
don't be silly. Just go back to your corner
do some more research. We have email. It's
great, it's amazing, we can email the world."
The ramifications of adding a few thousand
extra people just weren't clear to them.
And the way we view the workplace, a lot of
people still have this sort of romantic and
somewhat black and white notion of what the
workplace and what the workforce really is.
If you go back at the turn of the last century
90% of the workforce was manual and largely
agrarian in nature. That's a huge change from
today where plurality of the workforce is
comprised of knowledge workers, such as ourselves.
Today, in fact, you have to really look for
a manual workforce and it's about 20%. Yes?
>>Female #1: Sorry is that in U.S. or is that
international?
>>Jonathan Spira: These figures, almost all
the figures I will cite today are U.S. If
I go out of a U.S. figure I will explicitly
identify it as non-U.S. or worldwide or AMIA.
But thank you for mentioning that yes. As
of right now, I mean there's just so much
stuff we had in the U.S. that I tend to stay
with that and a lot of the data we need which
I'll get into a little later, like Bureau
of Labor Statistics and Census just isn't
as easily available worldwide.
Today as I mentioned knowledge workers are
the plurality of the workforce and that's
even the start contrast to 25 years ago where
a majority of the workforce was comprised
of industrial workers. And we saw the rise
of information workers and information professionals,
and this was foreshadowed in the cinema. One
of my favorite movies relating to this I don't
know, how many people here are familiar with
the movie Desk Set?
[pause]
Okay, 2%, no. [laughs] Spencer Tracy, Katherine
Hepburn, and the movie if you haven't seen
it, it's actually very relevant to what I'm
presuming most of us do. Spencer Tracy is
a computer salesman for a very large technology
company and he is selling and installing,
it's amazing he can do everything in this
film; he's selling and installing a large
mainframe. You remember those, that will run
a television network where Katherine Hepburn
who, just to show you it was 1950's, she was
the chief librarian and her name was Bunny.
You wouldn't quite see that happening in film
today; it's kinda, just wouldn't go over as
well.
But anyway and they end up with a challenge
and the challenge, and I think this is particularly
relevant at Google, is to answer a question.
Now if you think about it today we still go
to a search box, we type in a search query,
we get search results, sometimes depending
on how well we do it, and most people don't
know really how to use the tools, you get
564,768 results, that's probably a typical
number although I'm sure you guys could tell
me a more typical average number.
And the question that they posed, the challenge
question as they say on some shows in television
today, was what kind of car did the King of
the Watusis drive? It's not gonna give away
anything in the movie to say that the mainframe
didn't do terribly well in answering this
and of course Bunny and her team of librarians
did. I promise that was not a spoiler.
But it's interesting today if you go to Google
or any other tool and you just ask the same
question you're not gonna get an answer but
you'll get referred back to the movie.
[laughter]
[laughs] So you still don't know that he drove
a specially designed Pontiac, for those of
you who remember the late, lamented Pontiac
brand. I've always found that's a very interesting
example.
Now going back to how we work, as you can
see the figure that's going up, that is abstract
tasks. Routine tasks you can see are heading
down and declining and manual tasks which
declined dramatically through 1990 seem to
have plateaued and continue at that sort of
low level. So there's a tremendous amount
of change in just the way we look at jobs
and tasks.
I mentioned already that knowledge workers
comprise a plurality of the workforce. One
of the things we found out when we surveyed
Global 2000 companies, again this probably
won't be surprising to you, is that 80% of
the companies we talked to in pretty much
all the Global 2000 were simply not prepared
for the types of changes we're talking about.
Now what do I mean by not prepared? It's not
as if they're not using technology, they most
certainly are using technology, but they're
using a lot of technology, something I refer
to as technology sprawl which is kind of like
urban sprawl. And they have so much technology
[coughs] that they simply get in trouble because
they don't really know which system they're
using when and for what and so on.
So you end up with a lot of fun things happening
like somebody uses one content management
system to create something and then of course
we say, "Don't use Google for search," they
can't find stuff. And then somebody else recreates
the entire project because they couldn't find
it and they didn't know it was in the content
management system number 33.
I know content management is not a main thing
at Google but if you had a group of a thousand
employees, how many content management systems
do you think would be reasonable for this
like small group of a thousand employees?
What's a reasonable number?
[pause]
Anyone?
>>Male #1: One.
>>Jonathan Spira: One, yeah one would be actually
what I would think of, yeah one. How 'bout
97? [chuckles]
We were talking to a group at a, I'll just
say a large semiconductor company, and we
were helping them with, we were incorporating
some of their stuff into our research and
we happened to do a little inventory and they
were as shocked as I was, 97. That's a lot.
It's like for every 100 employees we basically
have a content management platform. Just can't
imagine how they find things.
So today especially with the change in where
we work and the type of work we do, with 40%
of the workforce working regularly, meaning
two or more times a week in non-traditional,
non-diverting environments, there's a lot
of change underfoot.
And we have the rise of the knowledge worker,
the knowledge worker, us again. I just wanna
throw out a definition from the book. The
easy definition is what a knowledge worker
is. I just say a knowledge worker is a participant
in the knowledge economy.
Then of course I have to define the knowledge
economy which is an economic environment where
information and its manipulation are the commodity.
And that's really dramatic contrast to the
industrial economy where you have raw goods.
Now, keep in mind at the end of the day a
lot of companies still build refrigerators,
automobiles, washing machines, and so on.
They build things, but the amount of information
intensive work that even goes into the creation
of these things and also into the manufacture,
think of robotics.
I don't know if anyone has toured a car factory
recently? if you go do the BMW tour either
at Munich or Spartanburg, or Leipzig you see
all these robots which in German they say,
"roborts" and people get confused about the
Roberts who are doing all the work here --
[laughter]
and they're doing all this stuff, it's like
a ballet carefully choreographed. So they
have to be controlled and managed so the people
on the floor who are managing them are knowledge
workers as well.
Knowledge workers, as you here at Google know,
we own our means of production. If we leave
and we don't come back the next day or check
in the next day or the next week we've taken
our means of production with us and with that
a lot of valuable information. A lot of our
knowledge work isn't tied to a specific location,
that's the beauty of the whole thing especially
when you have a beautiful campus like you
do, you can work almost anywhere.
And knowledge workers, especially people coming
into the workforce now have very, very different
and widely diverging expectations about how
to work.
And here's some typical knowledge workers
throughout the ages. It was very hard to get
the picture of the early knowledge workers
I should just add because they were not commonly
referred to as knowledge workers at the time
of course.
So what do knowledge workers do? Number one,
not a big surprise, they search. People are
constantly searching for things, most of the
time as we know they don't find things. There's
an oft cited stat that 50% of all searches
fail. I'd be interested actually to hear any
thoughts from the Google point of view in
general because this is a very, very, general,
overall statistic relating to corporate search
and all sorts of search.
But we found that 50% of the searches people
think succeeded actually failed and they don't
realize it. So what happens is they use the
result, the answer, again this is somewhat
problematic and I'm hoping that someone here,
I'm sure people are working on more natural
language search 'cause we like to actually
get into a question and actually get an answer
or several answer type of environment ultimately
to move away from 564,000 search results.
But if you use stuff that comes out of the
search where it's not the right thing, it's
not the best information and you don't realize
it's the old thing or of course the fact that
any clever 14 year old can create his own
website and it's really sometimes hard to
tell the difference between that and a well
establish site, you may end up using the wrong
information.
Now people, knowledge workers, spend a lot
of time creating, a lot of time as I mentioned
before recreating when you can't find stuff
because somebody put the very important document
in content management system 33 and you didn't
know that 33 existed, you didn't even know
your organization had 97 content management
systems. [chuckles] Just thinking about that
number is just mind boggling. You recreate
it.
Now recreating can be actually a very time
intensive thing because you form a team or
an ad hoc team, people spend lots of time
reinventing the wheel and doing what somebody
six months ago or three months ago already
did and never the twain shall meet. We spend
a lot of time communicating and we spend a
lot of time sharing information networking.
Now this is a chart with our stats that ran
in the Times about two years ago and it's
been updated since but I'm showing you this
not because it's old and obsolete because
one key number changed dramatically, the last
figure. Knowledge workers by and large think
for a living; we reflect, we think, that's
what I think we're supposed to be doing.
According to the stats we came up with a few
years ago we found that by the end of the
day after everything that's spent in the day
we have 12% left. Well I'm sorry to say I
was wrong; 12 percent was wildly optimistic.
When we redid the study and we used a larger
group and we refined our questions we found
out that at the end of the day 5% of the day
is left for thought reflection. Now that's
not very much.
Now if I recall correctly Google has a certain
percentage of time you can use for special
projects and things, am I getting that correct?
So that of course can be used for the thought
and reflection on whatever your current project
or special project might be. But if you don't
have that, if you only have 5% of your day
by the time you're just so oppressed by everything
else, well it doesn't really matter anymore.
So managing knowledge, knowledge worker, and
all that, those are huge challenges. I'm gonna
skip a drop about productivity for a minute
and go straight into information overload.
Now my book "Overload: How Too Much Information
Is Hazardous To Your Organization" is the
culmination of research as I mentioned that
I've been doing for the past 15 years. I'd
also like before I say anything else about
the book to mention that the book actually
does not end on the last page by design. We
created a website overloadstories.com to continue
the book and allow knowledge workers to put
their own stories about information overload.
Now there are probably about 40 or 50 stories
already in the book from people about their
travails with information overload but we
put the site up so that I can continue to
post new research and new ideas and as well
we can have readers, or potential readers,
or friends, or whoever put their own stories
and talk about either how they solved a problem
relative to information overload or in some
cases if you go there as you'll see, how information
overload is well killing them and just stopping
them from being able to finishing their work.
So I have a little definition for overload;
I just say its information overload there's
too much of a good thing because information
is good; too much information can just be
oppressive. But essentially it's an excess
of information that has some pretty dramatic
impact on how we work: it stops us from being
able to sometimes make decisions; it stops
us from processing information; and it stops
us from prioritizing tasks; it results in
incapacitation many times; it's a challenge.
Look at the causes of information overload
for a moment. We've dramatically, both in
terms of human and machine content creation,
we've increased our ability to generate content.
We've increased the number of modalities that
we have available for content to hit us, but
also to create the content. There's of course
email overload which is something that seems
to be the poster child for many people for
information overload, although in many cases,
probably more than 50%, email overload is
not the key problem for information overload,
it just seems to be something that's the low
hanging fruit.
Interruptions, interruptions in general when
I say that I'm referring to the way we have
set up our technology that allows us to have
it interrupt us whether it's incoming email
alerts, instant messages, phone calls, and
other things that are inopportune.
There is of course the fact that we have ubiquitous
connectivity which we generally think of as
a good thing but sometimes it would be nice
to go away to a mountain where there is nothing.
And there's lots of contradictory information
out there which weeding through it makes it
very difficult and hopefully again that people
here at Google are working on solving that
problem.
So I'm not gonna go into too much depth on
this because I'm sure you know and feel this,
but email is again poster child and many times
a huge challenge for all of us. We have too
much email and people tend to abuse it. I'll
get into some stats in a few minutes about
what happens when you do abuse it.
Search, I'm not even gonna go down that road,
I think you could educate me much better than
I can educate you.
Schedule, a meeting overload, I'm sure there's
some empathy here for that.
Unnecessary interruptions: we found that in
some cases as much as 28% of the knowledge
workers' day is consumed by these. One of
the most interesting things that came up I
researched though and this is why interruptions
tend to be something I come back to frequently
is the fact that interruptions don't occur
in isolation.
Interruptions come with a penalty. I found
this about seven or eight years ago and I
named it Recovery Time. Recovery Time is the
time it takes you to get back to where you
were before you had the interruption. Now
the amount of recovery time is significant;
it's 10 to 20 times the amount of the interruption
in general. So that means I could interrupt
you or something or someone or some technology
could interrupt you, break your thought, which
really is a distraction, even if it's only
30 seconds, it'll take five minutes for you
to get back to where you were.
Now you don't feel this, you don't sit back
and say, "Oh well, I had my interruption now,
okay recovery time's starting, good, okay,
yes." Now that's not really how it works;
it's very insidious, you don't feel it. In
the book I refer to it as "death by a thousand
paper cuts." Now, I think that's just how
you feel at the end of the day, that you've
just been cut away.
And actually I'm just realizing this slide
is out of date, there's 78.6 million knowledge
workers in the U.S., so I guess I have to
update my own slide.
Another thing that really, really contributes
to information overload is our view of how
things are urgent and important. It seems
that everything everyone does today is both
urgent and important at the same time. Now
that's a deadly combination.
When you have somebody sending you an email
and that person believes that what he is doing
is much more important than what you're doing,
it's urgent, important, he doesn't hesitate
to contact you two minutes after sending an
email saying, I see people smiling at this
one, "Did you get my email?" Or you get a
text or phone call, maybe both.
Now a lot of that, and that's not to blame
any particular generation or anything, but
I've noticed a trend that younger generation
coming into the workforce tend to feel more
entitled and we have a society that since
1973 has been steeped in instant gratification.
Anyone wanna take a guess what happened in
1973 that dramatically changed the landscape
for all of us, when you absolutely, positively
had to get something somewhere overnight?
Just, okay, big clue a few people recognize.
Yes. Fred Smith created FedEx. Before 1973,
if you wanted something absolutely, positively
overnight well you had to drive it there.
Now today, think about it, you order something
and if it's not on your desk by 10:30 the
next morning you're on the Web checking where
the truck is.
[laughter]
We get a little bit obsessive, I mean okay,
"Wait he's turning left, he'll be here now."
It's a little bit obsessive.
And we take this attitude and we bring it
into our expectations and how we work. Again,
especially if you think about in the last
15 years a lot of people have been brought
up with the, "You are very special Mister
Rogers," kind of attitude. You get awards
for your teen coming in last or even behind
last if there's such a thing. So you understand
why a lot of people just don't really put
this into perspective and they just don't
understand that you're doing something important
to you and they have to balance this.
There was a very, very good article in CIO
Magazine two years ago where a 21 year old
intern wrote something along the lines of,
"don't give me your tired, old apps and applications.
I want new, exciting, streamlined apps. If
you don't give them to me I'll leave and find
another company that does."
Now, first I don't think she has any clue
that in a large company it takes more than
a minute or two to change over your implementation
of whatever it is you have, maybe four or
five years for an SAP implementation, who
knows. But second, I don't think she had any
idea of what the unemployment rate for people
21 out of college might be. [laughs] I think
it's like 35-40%. So if she's gonna leave
she's not gonna get enterprise apps she's
gonna just get well unemployment.
But that really is a perspective that people
bring to this and it's something that I don't
think it's anyone's fault, I think it's just
a question of we have to be able to understand
this is why people burst in and interrupt
us because what I'm doing just isn't really
important and what the other person is doing
in that person's mind is.
So I mentioned technology-based interruptions
as well I'm just not gonna relate to them
too much of that.
Cognitive overload: at the end of the day
we're just feeling it. I mean there's just
so much out there and we just feel our brains
shutting down; same thing for tasks.
I wanted to show you this chart. I actually
made it five years ago and since the chart
is off the chart already I didn't really feel
the need to update it, but you can just see
if you go historically from the original tablet
to the point of the current tablet technology
how much relatively speaking our pace of information
creation, which I wrote the pace of information
overload, has just dramatically increased.
When you think of the fact that we have better
tools, but not necessarily tools that can
really address that type of geometric proportional
increase, it's scary.
Oft quoted, that's why I don't attribute this
to anyone, "More information has been produced
in the last 25 years than in the past five
centuries." But it's not a new problem. In
1545, Konrad Gesner warned of "a confusing
and harmful abundance of books." He wasn't
alone because in 1685, Adrian Baillet had
"fear of the multitude of books which grows
in a prodigious fashion every day."
Now, the cost of all this? We figure that
information overload costs the U.S. economy
$997 billion in 2010, and I'm probably being
conservative. I hate to say it but I'm probably
being conservative.
I know I've been going at a fast pace I just
wanna stop and make sure if there are any
questions that address anything?
Okay.
One computer, yea.
I wanted to mention how much reading 100 email
messages can take away from someone's day.
When we've surveyed people and studied over
their shoulder how they work, by the time,
on average, and this was I think we studied
100 people and again when you're doing this
type of work you can't, no one has the resources
to watch thousands and tens of thousands of
people, but we think it's a representative
grouping.
You can spend a half a day on 100 emails and
the typical amount I believe we calculated
the average amount of incoming email is 93,
so we're pretty close to what people get.
This is what information overload does do
to us: it lowers productivity; it lowers our
ability to comprehend things; it lowers our
concentration level.
I wanted to mention an interesting study by
a Swiss novelist, Rolf Dobelli, who maybe
Cliff can get him in to speak at some point
if Rolf is here I think he'd really do well
we well. Rolf wrote a white paper on how our
news addiction dulls our brain. Now before
I read Rolf, and I read Rolf's treatise in
April, I had actually cut back on my news.
I'll admit it I was a news junkie. I was addicted
to all sorts of news around the world: political,
international, just everything. I could read
lots of newspapers on the Web or on the tablet.
I could absorb all this and I didn't realize
what all this crack was doing to me.
And I decided to take a news holiday around
February because I was traveling a lot and
I just said, "I just can't deal with this,"
and I found that my ability to absorb more
lengthy, intense, deeper information improved.
I found myself more relaxed as well; I also
found I wasn't reaching for the tablets, "I
need that news."
And then in April a colleague found this white
paper that Dobelli wrote and he demonstrated
fairly scientifically how too much news simply
removes our ability greatly to digest deeper
tracts. And that's a huge challenge. If you
think about it, all these tiny sound bites
are just chipping away at our ability to comprehend
things.
So it's really a huge challenge for everyone,
but if we understand it we can do a lot to
try and mitigate the problem and address it.
That's one of the reasons I wrote the book
was because I felt that if we raise awareness
about the problem and we get a dialog going,
and we actually put out what the costs are
both in terms of the human toll as well as
the financial and emotional toll, maybe people
will do things about it.
For every 100 people who might be unnecessarily
copied on an email, thanks to the phenomena
of recovery time which I mentioned earlier,
we lose approximately eight hours of time.
Think of how many times you get an email where
there might be 50 or 100 people who really,
really didn't have to be on that email and
just imagine every time somebody replies and
we're all polite we write, "Great, thanks,"
and we hit reply to all just to make sure
that everybody sees how polite we are. And
each one starts this little cycle of this
recovery time, interruption, and your brain
stops and your flow stops and after all that
it's really easy to see where this goes.
In research we did at the end of 2010, 66%
of knowledge workers told us that they don't
have time in the day to get all of their work
done. That's not a surprise but this one is.
Ninety-four percent of the same group told
us that at some point in the day they typically
feel incapacitated and overwhelmed by information.
That 94%, that means 6% are taking a day off?
I mean I'm not quite sure what happened to
the 6%.
I wanted to discuss what a few companies are
doing. In particular I wanna use two examples
here: one, how many people here heard about
on Nielsen's Reply-to-All Experiment about
a year and half ago? On their Outlook client
they removed the reply to all button, they
didn't remove the functionality however. So
the first round of emails had to do with,
"Hey, they've taken away our reply-to-all."
The second had to do with, "Here's the keystrokes
you use to actually get reply-to-all."
Now just imagine how much time that wasted
and then the bad press picked it up and it
was just a fiasco because what they really
should have done, at least from my perception
and use a new UI design, is they should have
just separated the buttons if they were really
worried because make the knowledge worker,
make the user make a conscious thought, "Do
I wanna hit reply-to-all all the way on the
right or do I wanna just hit replay on the
left." That would have been my easy example
of what to do. I'm sure there are other things
that we could come up with as well, especially
if you are ccing a lot of people a little
warning box comes up and says, "Oh did you
really wanna cc 2,468 people? You're sure
about that?" Things like that.
On the other hand, I got a wonderful example
from the U.S. Air Force from a CIO there,
Peter Marksteiner, about a really great technique
he uses because a lot of people don't read,
no surprise I'm sure, most of the text of
an email.
We found that people on average make it through
the second paragraph barely. So if you have
the really important stuff in the third paragraph
or the fourth paragraph, how many times do
you send an email and the person is asking
you a question about what's in the fourth
paragraph? It's already been covered so you
have emails back and forth and back and forth
and it's like you have to answer the question
but it was originally there.
So what Colonel Marksteiner does and the great
thing about being in the military is that
he can actually order people to do this. It's
not like you have a real choice like, "you
will do this." He used this system which he
didn't invent but he discovered called BLUF.
If I had a chalkboard here I'd write it but
b-l-u-f, bottom line up front. And what he
would do is basically give a preamble to his
email saying, "I'm gonna cover, A, B, C, and
D." So he put the person on notice saying,
"I'm covering multiple topics and these are
the topics I'm gonna cover."
Now I tried doing that but unfortunately everybody
would email me back and say, "What's BLUF,"
as opposed to actually addressing the email
which shows, but then I started saying, "Okay
if I don't use the word BLUF but I follow
the concept I just write, 'Dear Sam and John
and Peter and Mary and Alice, I'm going to
cover these five topics in this email A, B,
C, D, and E,'" I found that people actually
paid more attention to what was in the email
as opposed to ignoring stuff.
I do try to keep my emails to one subject
whenever possible but I just wanted to mention
this because according to Marksteiner, I think
he said there must be at least 10,000 people
now using this in the Air Force and he gets
a tremendous amount of positive feedback.
It may not be for everyone and clearly were
not in organizations where we can order people
to do this, but if you actually set a little
preamble out without using BLUF, based on
my experience, you don't really need the back
and forth saying, "What's BLUF?" It may work.
Now, I wanted to share this email with you
[chuckles], this is from Marsh & McLennan
which is a large company in the insurance
field. Anybody wanna guess, and these people
own the to field, it's not the cc or bcc field,
I just wanna, and by the way on average five
emails like this per day went out. Anybody
wanna guess how many people are in the to
field here? We gave this to an intern to count.
[laughter]
[laughs] That's what interns are for. Sorry
if there are any in the room.
There's 5,000 people in the to field and this
was a very typical letter email that people
at Marsh would send out saying, "Hey, does
anybody know anybody at this company?" It
was called an all hands, it even had a name
it was called an all hands email and that
was a huge challenge because they would get
all these and of course what happened? Somebody
hits reply to all, to all 5,000 says, "No,
sorry, I don't." And then of course somebody
else hits reply to all saying, "Take me off
this list," things like that. Does that sound
familiar?
There was a meltdown actually Colonel Marksteiner
had told me about this great email meltdown
at Maxwell Air Force Base where he was attending
a conference with some really big brass, the
generals with the stripes and all that.
And when you go into a secure briefing room
you have to leave your Smartphone behind and
while they were in this briefing on the threat
from Russia and China and all that, really
high level information warfare stuff, somebody,
a clerk at Maxwell Air Force Base sent out
this little email about some sort of Bunco
card game or something like that and she accidentally
sent it to two bases, so it was about 50,000
people on the total mailing list.
Of course everybody hit reply to all, some
people commented, some people said, "Take
me off this God damned list," and things like
that. And by the time all the big brass got
out of the meeting, they went; they turned
their Smartphones back on and there was no
email.
While they were discussing this huge threat
from China, Russia, where ever the threat
is may be coming from [chuckles] this little
email about a Bunco card game completely brought
down the Air Force base, two bases actually.
So it's really interesting to see what can
happen.
I've been sort of giving tips a little bit,
which here may be preaching to the choir,
but I do tell people to read what people send
you and to read what you send. I get so many
emails where clearly the person just hasn't
read anything of what they put into the email
and it makes no sense.
I really try to practice what I preach and
read what I'm about to send someone, I try
and have some degree of empathy for people.
I try to use a variety of search tools, I
try to use arguments in my search, again I'm
at Google, you guys know this way better than
I do. And I try to do little things like I
keep my instant message status updated and
stuff like that.
I did wanna share a couple of things.
Some really interesting things from the surveys
that we do where people tell us how they remain
focused, obvious things like headphones, those
are pretty easy. I like the people who take
laptops and hide somewhere. One person talked
about going to the conference room, turning
the lights off, drawing the curtains, and
actually sitting under the conference room
table.
[laughter]
Somebody else talked about going to cafes
and Starbucks across town so nobody would
know them and then they were able to get work
done. But I really like the guy who turns
grumpy to the point of where no one will actually
talk to him until he's finished. I mean that's
just, "Get away from me." That'll get people
to leave you alone right? And stuff like that.
So this is a little logo we created. Information
Overload Awareness Day is October 18th this
year. We hope that you will commemorate that
day with us, we're going to actually, it's
the third time we're celebrating Information
Overload Awareness Day, the last two events
we did were online. This year we're planning
on doing an event both in person and online,
details to be announced. But we're bringing
a variety of people to just discuss the problem
and to discuss solutions of what can be done.
And with that I'd really invite you to share
your stories on overloadstories.com. Hoping
you have some good stories to talk about,
about the problem of information overload
that may help other people and to also read
what other people have already contributed.
And I'd like to thank Cliff for inviting me.
This is really coming to a place where information
is so important to people here and to the
business and to the future of society, I feel
very, very privileged to be here talking about
what I've done about information overload
compared to what you all are doing.
So thank you very much for having me and if
there are any questions I'm here for a while
so thank you.
[applause]
>>Male #2: My question, so I gather that you
don't like reply to all?
>>Jonathan Spira: Oh no I think it's useful
for certain purposes --
>>Male #2: Okay.
>>Jonathan Spira: I don't like when people
don't realize they're replying to all to 5,000
of their closest colleagues without realizing
it --
>>Male #2: Right.
>>Jonathan Spira: and just saying, "Great,
thanks."
>>Male #2: Okay.
>>Jonathan Spira: There are nuance levels
?
>>Male #2: Yes.
>>Jonathan Spira: of doing this here. It's,
I'm not against reply to all --
>>Male #2: Okay, I was gonna make the argument
for it. That if you ask a question and everybody
replies individually then they all reproduce
each other's work because they don't know
the question's already been answered. So given
that trade off do you have any specific rules
for how people can fix it or just hopefully
people will be intelligent --
>>Jonathan Spira: I have --
>>Male #2: about it.
>>Jonathan Spira: I have some idea, I didn't
mean to cut you off, I'm sorry. I have some
ideas. I think it's a question of reading
what people are asking and there are certain
emails where I say, "Please reply to me individually
because it's not important for the group to
see the answer." On other cases it's very
important and I emphasize, "Please reply to
all because I think it's very important for
the group to see everything."
But the problem is that in, I'd say more cases
than not, it's not necessarily important and
especially when you cc people unnecessarily
to begin with. I'd say the cc problem is worse
than the reply to all problem. We probably
wouldn't be having this question come up if
people kept the right number of people and
didn't tend to overly CYA their emails unnecessarily.
So it's not necessarily about the reply to
all but when you over cc people on the email,
reply to all can sometimes become dangerous
as the Air Force example gives us. But I'm
not against it at all. I use it all the time.
I just use it in the right place where I think
it's appropriate.
>>Male #2: Thanks.
>>Jonathan Spira: No, thank you.
[pause]
>>Female #2: Hi.
>>Jonathan Spira: Hello.
>>Female #2: I work in Internal Communications
and so we're super cognizant of not sending
emails that aren't important, but we have
a proliferation of modalities and I saw that
go by on one of the slides and I'd be really
interested in your thoughts about how other
organizations have handled what information
has to go to everyone in the company; what
information is just informational and need
to know; how do you separate out what's going
on in a building versus HR things.
We have just multiple kinds of information
and multiple modalities and we're sorting
it out and wonder if you had any thoughts
to share?
>>Jonathan Spira: It's a huge challenge and
I'd be happy to give you the longer answer
after --
>>Female #2: Okay.
>>Jonathan Spira: so I don't --
>>Female #2: Sure.
>>Jonathan Spira: but the short answer --
>>Female #2: They won't be bored 'cause they
--
>>Jonathan Spira: Okay.
>>Female #2: get a lot of emails from us.
[laughs]
>>Jonathan Spira: The short answer or the
medium answer is basically it's a very tough
question and it's a question of fine tuning
to your audience.
I'll give you an example: I had a conversation
with Jim O'Donnell who's the CEO of BMW of
North America and we were talking, this was
at a cocktail party, and he said, "Oh yeah
information overload, I had somebody print
out everything we send to our dealerships
and it was so and so many feet every week
of communication."
Now I had never thought until Jim mentioned
this of measuring information overload by
feet. I thought that was a great idea I said,
"Jim this is brilliant. I've never measured
how many feet or yards or meters information
overload could be." And he said, "Yeah, we
had like," I think he said seven feet or something,
and this is paper, printed, vertically stacked.
No one could digest, no one in a dealership
or anywhere, no human could digest all of
this information. So he said, "We have to
figure out something to figure out whom to
get the information to and via what modality
and what has to be pushed versus what has
to be pulled."
And I'm using that as an example because it's
a different type of problem but it's a very
similar problem at the same time. It's just,
it shows that you really have to think of
your audience and understand and then develop
strategies to not necessarily put everything
in front of someone's nose as opposed to just
making it available and hoping, but you can't
just have things where you hope somebody'll
know.
I mean that gets into the urgent and important
thing as well. I think the key thing here
is that we've lost our ability to understand
urgent, important, and all that. And until
we regain that balance, that gleichgewicht
in German, the sense of balance that keeps
us from going crazy, it's going to be a very
difficult challenge in corporate communications
and also external communications.
People who have to communicate massive amounts
of information about products, technology,
services, the government I mean there's, everything,
there's just so much you have to figure out
and nobody does it, you're never gonna satisfy
the audience.
I think you have to recognize that from the
beginning no matter what you're never gonna
get 100% satisfaction from your audience,
but you may find better ways especially by
going and polling your audience, by giving
choices.
And I would conclude my answer, which is actually
more long winded than I thought it would be,
by trying to develop multiple modalities so
that each person can actually choose how he
or she wants to receive information.
I always use the example one person's junk
mail is another person's L.L. Bean catalog.
If you don't care about L.L. Bean and you
don't want the boots, you're not really gonna
be happy that the catalog came. However if
you like L.L. Bean you're gonna be like, "Oh
great! I just needed to order something and
the catalog came," or "I got an email from
them," or something like that.
So it's really a question of perspective,
but I'd say the ability to give people a choice,
and again I'm happy to talk to you more about
this after and share some of our research
that looks at this in more even what Jim O'Donnell
said. But it's a matter of choice, giving
people choice.
I know you had a question.
>>Male #3: It was answered.
>>Jonathan Spira: It was answered, oh, okay,
groovy.
>>Male #4: I'll wrap up with a final question
then. So first of all thank you for coming,
we have a lot of GTD acolytes here that believe
in getting things done and so we really believe
in that technique.
But I wanted to go back to your question on
the difference between urgent and important
and the issue seems like a cultural one, one
you can't really solve by sending out an email
about what people should consider as urgent
and important.
So how have organizations tackled this and
basically made people aware of conflicting
priorities that are not within their own window,
that other people are working on important
things too?
>>Jonathan Spira: Well one of the things I've
recommended to people in terms of getting
the question of urgent versus important across
and it is a very, very tricky question and
it is cultural, generational, educational.
There are lots of things that come up in this,
is basically to put it all out on the table;
to give people an opportunity to say, to have
a discussion and to make, within work groups
in particular.
I think it actually is more pertinent in small
groups than on large organizational charts,
to make it clear, especially if you if you
start to see a problem crop up, that there
are way too many urgent and important requests
and that not everything, because I would say
if anything close to 80% of what people tend
to believe their doing is urgent and important
at the same time, is really to put this into
perspective.
If you can, if a manager within a work group
can have a dialog that establishes a protocol
and brings people into thinking about it,
again raising even the topic because people
are blithely unaware this is a problem to
being with. It's not as if people do this
deliberately, there's no design here. It's
more a question of it's a lack of awareness.
And just like with information overload I
know from what we've done when we've talked
to large corporations we know that just simply
raising a few facts about information overload,
some of the facts I've covered here, tends
to actually bring down the incidents of information
overload by 10 to 15%.
It's not a technology problem in fact I should
have said this earlier. I don't see information
overload today as a technology problem nor
do I see a lot of the solutions as being technology
based now.
I think that there are future things that
can be solved by technology but ultimately
I think that what we're really after is raising
awareness so we understand it's a very, very
human problem. It goes to core human frailties
and if we're able to address those I think
then we have a much greater likelihood of
being able to lower the overall incidents
of information overload and restore what really
we've decimated in the work life balance,
bring some time back both for us personally
as well as some productivity to the workplace.
And I think we'll all be just happier, more
relaxed, and more chill at the end of the
day. So that's really it.
>>Cliff: Alright, well thanks very much for
speaking with us today. It was an amazing
speech.
>>Jonathan Spira: Cliff, thank you so much
for having me and inviting me here. It's truly
an honor.